- Au moment de se dire
au revoir, encore nombreux sont
les voyageurs qui affirment,
en chemin, avoir été eraraînés
dans le tourbillon des retards
et des annulations.
- On était supposés partir
avant-hier pour s'en aller
à Barcelone, pu f finalement,
bien, notre vol a été annulé.
- Nous, on a quitté de Vancouver
et le vol était direct à Ottawa.
Il a été annulé.
- On a modifié notre vol,
j'ai pris trois vols
pour arriver à Montréal.
- Et chez Air Canada, qui a
supprimé 154 vols de son horaire
cet été, on demande aux clients
pénalisés de s'occuper eux-mêmes
du remplacement de leurs billets
d'd'avion.
(en anglais)
(brouhaha de voix)
Comme vous pouvez le voir,
à l'aéroport de Montréal,
la situation s'est quelque peu
améliorée, selon certains
membres du personnel,
mais les files sont très
impressionnantes encore
et de nombreux voyageurs disent
vivre carrément un casse-tête.
Or, la Charte canadienne
des droits des passagers aériens
permet aux voyageurs de réclamer
des compensations financières
allant entre 400 et 0000 $
en raison de retards
et annulations, 2800 $ en cas
de surréservations et 2400 $
pour des bagages perdus ou
retardés. Ma p pour y parvenir,
il faut faire la démonstration
que la faute revient bel et bien
au transporteur.
JACOB CHARBONNEAU, co-fondateur,
président-DG de volenretard.com
- Bien qu'Air Canada annule
des vols, bien qu'il y avait
des places à bord des avions,
on sait très bienueue
présentement, il y a
des problèmes d'équipage,
il manque de pilotes,
il manque d'éqpapage,
il manque de personnel
dans les aéroports.
- Et si la compagnie aérienne
visée neemembourse pas
son client dans les 30 jours
comme la loi le prescrit,
c'est l'Office des transports
du Canada qui doit examiner
les dossiers, où l'attente
s'étire jusqu'à un an et demi